I definitely look up to my sister she
has a lot of great things that I can
learn from and I think she's an awesome
thank you maybe Kimberly is my best
friend there she's never gonna be
replaced I like to do martial arts and
then I also like to do basketball I like
to do archery and play piano I have a
lot of favorite subjects I like math and
English and social studies and science
and technology I like technology the
best these are some of the programs that
I did but I also really like science I
like challenges
we saw some videos of people doing
weather balloon launches online we
thought that it would be a really fun
family project to do
a weather is basically just a very large
balloon their use well to see what the
weather is going to they send up
different instruments attached to the
bottom of the weather balloons and
they'll transmit the data and saying oh
it's gonna be partly cloudy there are
16,000 weather balloons launched every
day around the world the weather
companies the forecasters only recover
30% of them the other 70% are still
floating in space
so they're not well there is some work
there somewhere in the earth by the
first launch we didn't really have a
goal we just wanted to get it off the
ground we didn't even understand as much
science then we were kind of just
letting go of it and hoping that I get
relations were right
[Music]
our flight computer keeps track of a
number of things including altitude
latitude longitude speed temperature
pressure voltage current and out there
is a lot of data that we can learn from
the first launch went to 78,000 feet the
images were awesome when we first saw
them we screamed it's just the blackness
of space and then there's lucky sitting
there in the middle of it right on the
horizon the first media that kind of
wrote an article about us was a local
tech news website called a geek wire and
then someone from the Washington Post
saw it and so they wrote an article
about it and then other people saw and
they wrote articles about it you're
gonna have to bring the okay take a
launcher you're gonna meet the president
our parents told us that we were going
to what has science fair
well hello everybody welcome to the
White House when he actually walked
through the doors we were all incomplete
and like admiration for dogs because
this is President Obama he was really
easy to talk to he is really friendly
he talks to all of these like famous
world leaders and he makes decisions
that affect the fate of our country and
we're just 90 11 year old girls who did
a science project this is a rough
drawing of the flight computer and we'll
probably put the VI sets are here I am
making some changes to our original
design because we're adding some new
components and taking off some
[Music]
on the second lunch we added a bigger
balloon because we wanted it to go
higher and we also wanted it to go
faster we added an ABR s radio tracker
which sent us location and altitude data
in almost real time however the APRs
might not be very accurate at ground
level to having the GPS unit as well is
very helpful
we rewired the voltage / current / power
sensor so it would connect to a solar
panel that we installed on our
spacecraft to measure how much current
it was getting from the Sun and we had
our hypothesis that as our spacecraft
went higher we would have more solar
current because we thought that since
there's less particles in the air it
wouldn't block the sun's rays the last
thing that we changed was our Lego
minifigure we thought that she would be
a good role model because she's a girl
who's strong and she's brave and she
doesn't give up even when things are
hard soon it was time for launch
we couldn't believe that it actually
went a hundred than 1000 feet I think we
screamed again our current data was
really interesting because our solar
panel was producing more current as the
altitude was going up which indicated
that our hypothesis was correct getting
something correct especially when you
don't know that much about the subject
always feels good
I hope but more kids especially girls
follow paths and do projects like ours
and stem and I hope that our projects
teach them that they can do whatever
they want if they put their heart into
it they don't have to stick with
whatever is girly or boyish girls are
awesome and girls can do anything
[Music]